une fois encore les urgences font le
plein la grippe continue de monopoliser
les services hospitaliers
et cette année c'est bien pire que l'an
passé si dans les quatre dernières
semaines
on ne sait entre 1800 et 2000 coop par
semaine donc presque le double de la
plus grosse semaine de l'an dernier
partout où elles frappent la grippe à
trois souches différentes en tête le
h3n2 où la grippe australienne qui
représente selon les pays plus de 50 à
80% des cas ensuite il y à l'influenza
de type b et de ligne et yamagata la
griffe japonaise ou encore le h1n1 un
internat même journée on voit les trop
vireux ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois de
vivre sans que j'avais jamais vu ça
auparavant fait qu évidemment il ya
beaucoup de jeunes malades
ça met de la pression sur le système de
santé depuis octobre dernier c'est
grippe n'ont cessé de gagner du terrain
partout au canada même propagation aux
états unis 49 états sont maintenant
touchés tout comme au royaume uni les
morts s'ils comptent par centaines et
les décès sont très rapides car l'offre
qui peine 6 12 ans a été frappé par une
fièvre de 39,5
il est mort deux jours plus tard dans
les bras de sa mère brenda n'attendez
pas dit elle allait voir un médecin
au moins 37 enfants américains ont
d'ailleurs succombé à la maladie
c'est plus que les dernières années la
souche la plus virulente cette année
donc le h3n2 c'est la même souche que la
grippe de hong kong qui avait tué en
1968 un million de personnes et chaque
fois que cette souche refait son
apparition
la force du vaccin contre la grippe est
plutôt faible cette année son efficacité
en moyenne ne serait que de 30%
seulement les campagnes de vaccination
sur malgré tout prises d'assaut car
selon les autorités sanitaires
cela reste le meilleur rempart contre
les autres souches de grippe en général
pour les plus vulnérables vers 9 heures
selon ce médecin d'atlanta ce sont les
plus âgés et les jeunes enfants qui
écope majoritairement aux grands maux
les grands remèdes
lui et son équipe ont mis sur pied cette
impressionnante unités de soins annexé à
l'hôpital pour accueillir
sécuritairement les nombreux malades
dans d'autres états certaines écoles ont
décidé de fermer leurs portes ou de
désinfecter les classes seule bonne
nouvelle
il semble que globalement l'activité
grippale demeure élevé
mais commence à ralentir ici frédéric
arnould radio canada montréal